Points are good and we use them a lot when we look at real world data, but
what's even better than a point? A line. This is an example of a line on a
coordinate plane. Now this line might not seem that interesting, but its got a
whole personality that we're going to talk about. Notice that this line has a
ton of points on it. I have points here, here, here and even anywhere along this
line all of these are points, but there are two points on this line that I find
most interesting. I want you to check the two most mathmatically interesting
points on this line and I should say this is a debatable one. So if you get a
different answer from me it just means we are thinking differently which is
okay.